[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey man we're gonna grab lunch at that
noodle place I won't join now thanks man
I'm cornettos cool cool
[Music]
[Music]
hey dudes super excited exclamation
point going to be a little late start
without me period
[Music]
are you ready to order or did you want
to start with a drink um I'm fine with
the water oh no no no not on my birthday
my thing is having no water sponge to
get the beer in seriously I got you
don't worry about domestic here's your
$5 for next time
no all right I'll the beer thanks thanks
for joining us have a great night
you
rough night
stop I'm here to surprise you I knew you
weren't really looking forward to
tonight here's fine you know same old
not a big deal okay well I have an idea
it's the greatest one ever go with me on
this we bust out a board game we drink a
couple beers on me and I just so happen
to have procured a fabulous movie that I
think you're gonna love because found it
on your DVD shelf I don't know sounds a
little pricey II
[Music]
you
[Music]